Oh
what is going on YouTube recently I was
driving around and I decided to turn on
something that I haven't turned on in a
while my brain now I turned on the radio
oh my god
the hot garbage that was spewing out
those speakers I wanted to punch like a
baby llama in the faces what happened to
hip-hop my friends but I'm gonna just
let you know hip-hop prepare yourself
because y'all ready know what it is
LGI so baby let's get it let's go go
come on what the hell is going on let me
finish my train of thought
I remember when lyrics used to be some
[ __ ] and I understood what the rapper
was rapping about but apparently all you
need is a beat yeah and I remember back
in the day there was a lot of gangster
rap but at least I understood what the
hell was going on the song I'll put a
clock in your mouth [ __ ] uh he gonna
kill me with his gun dumb asses always
be using the same excuses for shitty ass
hip-hop oh [ __ ] for this beat go ham Oh
word what's the same thing what's he
saying man y'all like your beauty
apparently we are running out of slang
so we have to make acronyms for
everything that's right go ham I am sick
and tired of never listen to a rap song
and every two seconds gotta go on urban
dictionary just to figure out what the
who saying hey [ __ ] hot as a
[ __ ]
that's not even ham that's ham you
forgot the fourth quarter fine does
everybody's gonna do it I'm gonna make
my own words too then
hey what's up dog you have a dad what's
that dumb ass [ __ ] and to hell with the
word Yolo Yolo Yolo Yolo
if I hear one more person say Yolo you
are really gonna find out if you only
live once
that's right Drake you have
single-handedly ruined my life with your
kick-ass hairline and your shot the
eyebrows I hate your nuts
it just sounds stupid Yolo sound on the
name of a Korean yoga shop welcome to
your toys so where the pie see disorder
oh that's a donkey you know that one
yeah that's a good one huh before this
dude put out the something you didn't
know that you only live once
[ __ ] nas has already said once hip hop
is dead even the way you rap about
having sex is the craziest [ __ ] I've
ever heard of my life i'ma beat the
[ __ ] up oh you gonna beat her [ __ ] up
this is the literal definition of
sexually assaulting someone ladies how
are you even listening to that [ __ ] in
the club he can beat my poofier
the dude is trying to scramble your eggs
run [ __ ] that's like Missy Elliott
coming out with a song I'm a chop your
dick up oh oh [ __ ] she gonna try my Big
O Street makjang yeah you always cool it
by yourself feelings like these self
laugh being with your single friends we
see this is my grandfather exorcise me
these are called Asian exercises one
swish delayed two three